you grew up in the uh in pennsylvania
man you grew up out and were you like an
amish country did you ever have any
interaction with the honor there's a lot
of amish around wow yeah lancaster
that's i i was like 30 40 minutes west
of amish country but they're around dude
did you ever get approached by him
because i could see you being
like i definitely if i'm amish and i'm a
you know i don't want to say a milk
drinker yeah yeah but if i'm somebody
that's close to that udder maybe i'm
just getting milk yeah yeah he saw me
yeah that guy's chugging milk obviously
like uh that guy's eight percent right
there yeah they uh no but you'll see him
we used to yell at him when we were kids
what would y'all say like nice [ __ ]
horse dumbass
get a car you [ __ ] idiot you drive
past him
it was fun now i look back on him like
that's very inappropriate the crazy part
is people that yell out like queers
these aren't gay people still that's i
mean they're gay for women phobic and i
don't stand for it yeah that's funny
yeah driving by an amish dude and a
buggy be like [ __ ] homo
he's gotta be like what the [ __ ] oh dude
a couple black dudes called me the n
word a couple months ago dude and it was
like that kind of brightens your day a
little i felt
you know i was like you promised you
know i didn't know what to say that's so
cool thank you guys i'll like say it
again man it's cool when you guys yeah
we like it
i remember when i was young somebody was
throwing rock me and my buddy were
fishing it was a black friend of mine
who's i think in jail for murder now man
my friend devin but he um
he
uh we're fishing in some white some
racist white dude or some somebody
racist who looked white from where we
were was up on these training tracks he
starts throwing rocks at us
and yelling the n word right
and so i jump out and i'm like not me
dude i'm saying like at least
yeah don't get me
you're getting the wrong guy you're
gonna hit me with a rock
but that [ __ ] was wild dude the amish
every once in a while get smoked by like
trucks
dude they're driving horse horse and
buggies
the truck truck driver will go wide
right and just splatter them rub around
horses and [ __ ]
it's bad really and they hit him and i
guess uh oh
would you rather get hit from the back
with a trucker from the front
like definitely from behind
boss
definitely i don't want to see that
thing coming dude you don't i don't want
to have one set i don't want to have one
second to be like oh
here it comes i just want to
just fade to black just
that'd be nice
oh what sound would you make that's not
how i think about that
wait am i in a car or i'm just getting
no you're just walking you're out there
walking something's not going good yeah
right yeah something's gone wrong
yeah something is wrong i'm walking out
there and i'm walking and yeah i
definitely wanted to be from behind yeah
i don't dude because if you see it
coming your last you know you're gonna
be trying to get out of the way for the
last second that's gonna be your last
thing you do and the saddest part if one
of your friends saw you because you'd
probably put your hands up like yeah he
put his hands up to try to stop it
like you see that idiot a fire truck hit
him he put his hands up yeah you would
do you of course you would
yeah that would be tough man it'd be
time to figure that out so was there a
lot was there amish people like in your
like was it a was there like would you
all go to any amish markets i'm just
trying to wonder some of these amish
markets and [ __ ]
i didn't really go to those but they
have uh we have like mennonite kids in
our school wow yeah
chick that would wear like a bonnet yeah
they were like because there's there's
there's levels to amish and there's
mennonites that i don't think follow
like the no electricity and [ __ ] but
they'll like drive the only color their
car can be as black they can drive it
like twice a week or some crazy [ __ ] oh
really yeah oh damn they're not all like
strict no electricity know this yeah
oh dang so they got some like batman
mennonite kind of yeah there's a lot of
those guys
damn
i didn't realize that dude
they're flying dude they're out there
yeah we tried i know we tried for a
while to get a real amish or uh somebody
semi-amish on here and we couldn't do it
i was at a i was at a football game in
indiana there's a lot of them in indiana
and ohio too and they uh these dudes
were just on rump springer
[ __ ] tailgating with us wow and they
were getting wrecked dude damn they were
jacked from all the [ __ ] work oh
you're just getting ham just idiots
they're dumped oh they could build a
birdhouse with their tongue
the amish they'll build a damn they
would like and they speak with a crazy
accent really i can't even do it i don't
know they call us the english
oh wow yeah
i didn't know that so they don't look at
so do they look at themselves as even
like
i mean i guess they look at themselves
as human yeah for sure and they look at
themselves as religious but they don't
look at themselves as like
english or anything no they think we're
the english and they're the
i don't know what the [ __ ] they are
germans damn yeah they're wrong yeah
that's wrong across the board
and where some of the women did y'all
see some of them um
nice babe it's rare but if you if you
see a hot amish chick it's like damn
that's good that's that's my queen yeah
it's in a beautiful flowery dress
yeah no one's touched her oh what a
sweet angel
stinks like hell
you think they smell good or bad no they
smell bad oh yeah they do smell bad i
hope that well yeah they're not gonna
care oh yeah
they don't smell great yeah there's
something kind of room i feel like
there's some sense of romance about it
um yeah for sure because you i think you
always romanticize like a woman with a
pail of water and you know and you you
can help her hey i'll be you know yeah
let me help you i'll build us a boat or
something you know like i feel like and
you can almost you could use anything to
get some excitement you could be like
hey let's you know have you ever done
this and you just do like the dougie
form or something you know you just do
like something like have you ever done
the soldier boy you just do something
like that just yeah you do something
crazy that they've never seen yeah yeah
yeah they've never even seen it
[Laughter]
you're incredible this is gonna be yeah
this is a hit yeah
it could be anything to hit yeah like
the soldier hit that even if you just do
this
smash it and they're like oh my god i've
never even thought of doing that yeah
i just think some of the ways you could
hit on amish women would be insane dude
for sure or if you did this thing you
know like oh
yeah they might burn you yeah yeah yeah
they might burn you you might get lit
soldier boy they might burn you they
might be like dude that's witchcraft
yeah we're not having that here
imagine how peaceful you think it's
peace will be an amish on the inside of
them or you think it's i don't know
that's the thing like you were saying it
might be great yeah just [ __ ] working
doing real work like farm work building
[ __ ] and then you go to sleep oh
yeah i don't know and you don't no one
around you is [ __ ] doing good yeah so
that helps oh but not on instagram no
you're not so you're not you but i
wonder if there's an intense fear of
missing out because you're seeing you
see one car go by and some you know
there's a little
you know there's some a woman with a
bathing suit you've got to lose your
mind
yeah
if you're just sitting behind a horse
going [ __ ] four miles an hour down
that [ __ ] highway
convertible flies by and something you
just smell like glass you hear one
second of cool music
yes what the [ __ ] was that yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] dude and yeah and dad's
like get your eyes back in your head
why are we doing this this sucks
it must feel like you're on the most
insane halloween ever i feel like it's i
mean yeah if you ever get and they do
rum spring it and that's as long as you
want it's not like one year some of them
stay out
for like 10 years have a regular life
and then they're like
back to amish
guys i gotta let y'all know he's going
back yeah i'm breaking probably [ __ ]
sick you just burn out in real life you
just go so hard go as hard as you can
get addicted to [ __ ] yeah then you're
like dude i'm going back back to the
farm i bet when you roll back in there
though i bet people are coming up and
smelling your breath and wanting to
touch you
like what was it what was it like yeah
i've been doing code edward was that
drums
i've been doing cocaine yeah it's crazy
you know how much we get done around
here
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you